si vous sentez concerné vous lever les
bras le bras d'ailleurs surtout ce
moment cammas qui comme 76 % des femmes
76% des femmes ne couche pas le premier
soir et paris que 76% des femmes ne
couche pas le premier soir valérie
benaïm je sais c'est la première heure
non c'est pas premier toit banon vous
coucher à partir de quel soin de l'après
midi vous êtes l'asean aipa conseil
prenez soin d'informer cyril ça dépend
quoi ça peut arriver des palissades et
pas vous est déjà arrivé de te coucher
avec un mec au premier soir dit la
vérité aussi qu'on puisse bien sûr pas
vraiment jour vous l'avez opposer quand
même avec le recul non périence bien
connues énoncées ci dessus dire si on ne
l'a pas dit qu'on peut dire quoi qu'on a
loupé quelque chose ou pas du tout non
j'ai pas ce que j'ai voulu dire mais
j'ai voulu dire simplement si ça m'est
arrivé mais ça peut arriver à tout vous
est déjà arrivé mais n'ont jamais
coucher le premier soir je ne m'en
voulez bien tu agis plus masculin que
féminin non non s'il vous plaît pas tous
se répandent et je t'assure que non mais
je vous assure que non parce qu'en fait
j'ai besoin d'être courtisé j'ai besoin
moi j'avais valenciennes j'ai besoin
comble alors l'agent me chômeurs il est
pas content
parce que moi j'ai une théorique dictée
par une femme ayant une femme philosophe
qui a dit un jour il faut toujours
coucher le premier soir pour être sûr de
pas tomber amoureux d'un mauvais coup
plus vous attendez à [ __ ] et de
développer des sentiments pour la
personne et si la chimie ne se fait pas
le jour où chansons et bien tout ça
serait un croyant qu'il résistera pdc
raison d'indicés ce qu'il aurait dû
faire ce serait moi marié la télé qui
fera jour où il s'est pleinement pas
d'accord avec toi jean mi parce qu'à un
moment donné le premier sort n'est pas
amoureux peut-être que dans deux mois
six mois les deux fronts amoureux et
l'amour sera pas le même
oui c'est le shimmy shimmy shimmy et
nous fait alors jean-michel ils couchent
pas le premier savoir ce qu'ils font
c'est ce combat n'a alors battu non moi
ce que vous consommez soir évidemment
quoi bah oui à la première heure
bien sûr très très important parce que
si laconique se fait pas ça c'est très
clair
la collection sexuelle ne se fait pas le
sexe c'est le réacteur du couple y met
et la connexion ctoc doute en bonne et
due connais rien si la collection
sexuelle ne se fait pas c'est même pas
la peine de tenter le coup de ses draps
les matelas vous et j'irai me coucher le
policier
à temps oui alors oui oui mais quel âge
est pas couché le premier sens que ça
fait d'être au talent pour le fais dans
mon caractère d'état n'avait pas connu
qu'alain donc arrêté sur terre et en
plus je sais moi j'ai tendance à dire
qu'on peut coucher le premier soir comme
ça au moins c'est fait mais c'est
compliqué et oui à 100 bourré
non le deuxième chaque fois le deuxième
a toujours le deuxième soir mais il ya
un premier soir on la ramène est
deuxième oui géraldine vois ça m'est
arrivé bien sûr mais tu roules un drame
c'est pas grave c'est géraldine maillet
bah oui mais après très romantique oui
mais si la force
bah je fais de bien ben pourquoi pas
vous bah oui mais bien pour moi vous
n'aviez c'était giral images pour moi
vous n'aviez jamais couché avec elle ou
des traitements non mais c'est un point
commun voilà exactement qualité non mais
c'est quoi
et oui c'est éviter qu'on poste et a
longtemps quand j'étais jeune ne vous
êtes toujours jeune m'a moins que jamais
mariés les missionnaires jamais a dit
[Applaudissements]